buonasera buonasera grazie allora potete
mai dire che queste foto appartengono
alle stesse persone
la risposta giusta è un no per cortesia
perché nella prima fascia ci sentiamo
alquanto precarie brutte depresse
momenti difficili della vita nella
seconda eravamo da heroes maratea gli
eroi del sud che si occupano che social
innovation 15 che davamo massa bruttezza
e questa bellezza a cosa e sono legate
probabilmente alle storie che ci stiamo
raccontando c'è un film da big fish in
cui a un certo punto si dice bisogna
fare attenzione alle storie che ci
stiamo raccontando perché un giorno
finiremo per diventare quelle storie e
allora che succede
oltre a noi anche la nostra città
se la passa un po così no oscilla tra
due rappresentazioni quella della napoli
piena di monnezza ammuine disordini
luoghi comuni inquinamento delinquenza
che possiamo dirle tantissime e la
napoli meravigliosa cartolina col sole
il mare la cultura ho tutto quello che
praticamente la fa quasi pensare come un
paradiso questa oscillazione non fa bene
alla nostra città per cui abbiamo
pensato di creare un format cui mettere
insieme e bellezza e bruttezza integrare
queste immagini per dare la possibilità
così di pensare a una città diversa alla
città nuova
da dove nasce questo format nasce da una
mia crisi
io sono di attrice del format perché mi
sentivo appunto come nella prima foto
diciamo come spesso mi succede molto
precaria a un certo punto mi sono
soffermata sul precariato sulla sua
bruttezza che è indiscutibile precariato
possiamo parlarne tantissimi modi non
solo rispetto alla professione ma tutti
quanti quelli che sono l'assenza dei
voti valoriali esistenziali il
terrorismo e quant'altro no fino a
quando l'ho raccontato questi vi
assicuro che ero specializzata massimo
dei voti tanti complimenti piangevo
tutti quanti giorni perché diceva perché
devo fare io amo la mia città romane
voglio andare quindi poi ha cominciato a
pensare al precario diversamente
guardando alla bruttezza del precariato
vorranno anche la bellezza
il precariato perché il precario e un po
con un funambolo che cammina sui su un
vuoto esistenziale no però sta comunque
su un filo diciamo che lui allenato dei
muscoli che gli altri non ancora
allenato probabilmente le generazioni
precedenti hanno allenato che gli
consentono di stare in equilibrio su
quel filo e qual è
cioè cos'è che ci manca molto spesso per
cui ci per cento solamente come brutti è
la speranza perché perché spesso il
futuro che ci immaginiamo e il futuro
vecchio il futuro dei nostri genitori
quello del posto fisso del mutuo e fino
a quando non siamo in grado di
immaginarci un futuro diverso non
potremmo mai fare qualcosa di diverso di
nuovo di speranzoso da questa follia
come diceva einstein nella crisi che
nasce l'inventiva pianto dopo pianto
bruttezza dopo bruttezza guardandola per
bene ho incominciato a percepire un po
di bellezza va ho detto non posso dire
un'idea e quindi cosa ho fatto con lego
due professioni che esercito quella dei
giornalisti e degli psicologi sono
psicologo e giornalista e mi chiedevo
alla fine entrambe le professioni
professioni lavorano con le domande no
perché il giornalista fa delle domande
lo psicologo le domande solo che il
giornalista non si preoccupa
dell'effetto e quelle risposte a quelle
domande avranno sulle persone lo
psicologo invece utilizza la domanda per
fare un intervento psicologico che
promuove il benessere promuover bello
allora dico magari faccio un format in
cui faccio andare a napoli psicoterapia
e perché perché il tipo di comunicazione
proposta era una comunicazione autentica
che non negava la monnezza ma mostrava
accanto alla monnezza
la cartolina le patologie nascono dalle
scissioni dalle parti nude sono separate
rifiutiamo e buttiamo al di fuori di noi
invece la guarigione
nasce dall integrità da mettere accanto
e spazzatura e cartolina e la
psicoterapia di napoli permetteva di
fare questo questa la rete per creare
napoli in treatment questo siamo un po
lo staff di sembrerà strano perché c'è
anche il sindaco de magistris si dice
anche lui perché anche lui ha
partecipato al processo sotto il primo
che io ho intervistato interrogato sulla
città fino a arrivare a tutti questi
personaggi tra cui c'è anche se riina la
riconoscete da che parte uno staff misto
fatto di comunicatori psicologi
psicoterapeuti esperti del web grafici
registi attori
perché perché era importante mettere
insieme le bruttezze bellezze di tante
professioni e quindi per questo dimostra
questa slide perché in realtà ogni
professione cioè le sue bellezze e le
sue bruttezze ma anche lavorare in
gruppo non è sempre solamente bello che
è stato stupendo sotto la rete
importante portare avanti il progetto è
anche molto complicato e difficile ma
anche noi se nati in psicoterapia
perché in realtà krisma falsi della
supervisione di professori importanti di
psicoterapia italiana tra cui renzo
carli giovanni madonna antonella
bozzaotra e facciamo supervisioni per
guardare la nostra bruttezza come staff
non negando la e mettendo accanto a
quella la nostra bellezza portando
avanti il progetto infatti qui mostrò
più o meno le puntate come si svolgono
il prima la prima che abbiamo visto un
primo flash avete visto in realtà il
titolo era una paziente speciale il tema
ogni volta il tema variava della puntata
della seduta che sono vinti seduto in
tutto la relazione cittadini istituzione
è il sintomo l'ansia generalizzata
perché lo partiamo proprio da un
problema che a napoli da una bruttezza
di napoli per poi allargare guardare la
bellezza come invitando in questa
psicoterapia di gruppo che non avete
visto nessuna immagine che riguarda
questo ma se eseguite sul nostro sito
insomma le vedrete
invitiamo sulla sedia rossa di questa
terapia di gruppo o un rappresentante
dell'istituzione un cittadino o un
associazione che racconta rispetto a
quel sintomo cosa sto facendo qui non
negando il problema mostra la risorsa
che ogni giorno in quel tipo di attività
che sta svolgendo il format fa su
videometrò il canale tv che sta nelle
kumar e funicolari e metodi napoli
perché per credo a raggiungere tutta la
città
la napoli buona quella che si definisce
buona quella che guarda agli altri come
a dire madonna come bello il nostro
presepe quelli passoni sono una
schifezza no e la napoli ma la mente che
in realtà poi non sono così separate che
ogni quartiere salmone malamente
all'interno uno dei luoghi che a napoli
sono un po l'emblema della commistione
tra bene e male tra bellezza e bruttezza
tra cartolina e monnezza è proprio il
rione sanitario né sanità che di solito
assurge un po alle cronache locali e
nazionali proprio per temi molto brutti
no la camorra la delinquenza
e però al suo interno a molti paradossi
perché un luogo di estrema bellezza del
luogo che ha dato la nascita a totò per
dirne una è un luogo che tra i suoi
vicoli nasconde delle ricchezze immense
umane e monumentali e proprio 17 ottobre
del 2015
proprio a rione sanità abbiamo fatto
questa serata splendida in una cornice
meravigliosa delle catacombe di san
gennaro in cui il napoli in treatment
con i suoi pazienti con con la rete che
abbiamo attivato associazioni cittadini
istituzioni
lo stesso sindaco alcuni presidenti
delle municipalità abbiamo siglato un
contratto un contratto di presa in cura
di napoli di attività di cura appunto
della bellezza di napoli e ognuno di
loro ha siglato un contratto in una
serata che noi amiamo definire
democratica perché non ci sono stati
tappeti rossi non è stata una serata a
glitterata una serata alla moda ma una
serata in cui ci siamo seduti tutti sul
palco l'istituzione con il cittadino con
tina la fruttivendola con l'associazione
con il presidente delle avrò una serie
di attori tutti allo stesso piano tutti
allo stesso livello per non lavorare con
per napoli e nella stessa serata abbiamo
mandato in onda la psicoterapia che
abbiamo fatto con il sindaco de
magistris che molto umilmente poi si è
messo in gioco con noi una sera a
palazzo san giacomo
raccontandoci anche la sua bruttezza è
stato molto particolare perché poi
persone così pubbliche così interessate
alla bellezza a farsi vedere belli in
qualche modo si è seduto col così
insieme a noi tranquillamente parlandoci
anche delle sue difficoltà firmando il
nostro contratto
ci sono alcune delle foto il presidente
sì a latina la fruttivendola che fa dei
quartieri spagnoli un corso di cucina
per gli immigrati e quindi tutti abbiamo
siglato insieme questo contratto dal 17
ottobre
abbiamo fatto diverse cose e un corso di
comunicazione per gli ordini
professionali e soprattutto l'eco
treatment fest l'eco treatment e fosse
stato un festival dedicato all'ecologia
nei suoi nelle sue mille declinazioni
della mente dell'ambiente prendendoci
cura in quattro giornate dei rifiuti
ambientali sociali personali relazionali
del rifiuto ad ampio spettro è venuto
con noi paul connet che gratuitamente si
è prestato a quattro giorni i folli se
vogliamo partendo da un convegno con dei
professori del suo ruhr sola della
federico ii professori di psicoterapia
parlando del rifiuto appunto ad ampio
spettro due giornate di un eco ghema
bosco di capodimonte e qui abbiamo fatto
una caccia al rifiuto quindi potendo
parlare dei rifiuti della città dei
rifiuti personali dei rifiuti
relazionale che che spesso rifiutiamo e
bastano mettiamo fuori di noi senza
protezione prendere cura e l'ultima
giornata al carcere di secondigliano al
carcere di secondigliano siamo entrati
nel carcere abbiamo portato la città
all'interno del carcere volendoci
prendere cura proprio di questa
bruttezza non la bruttezza per
antonomasia il carcerato questo carcere
lontano dalla città ha messo fuori no
l'emblema della scissione che porta la
patologia e la città è entrata nel
carcere ed è stata un'emozione
meravigliosa noi ci siamo emozionati a
sentire la canzone che i detenuti
avevano composto paul connett ha
inserito il nostro al nostro viaggio
all'interno del carcere nel suo pub
point insomma che porta in giro per il
mondo parlando di zero waste è stata una
giornata in cui la bellezza e la
bruttezza si sono mescolate si sono
unite in una armonia se vogliamo
particolare poiché proprio la scissione
è stata superata
il carcere proprio il punto massimo no
del dl tenere fuori del mettere fuori
nella
montanare il carcerato deve stare in
qualche modo distante no perché può
essere pericoloso in qualche modo per la
nostra
per la nostra idea di bellezza e di
società e invece questo in questo
carcere dove loro fanno anno questo
distretto ecodistretto a km zero in cui
smaltiscono e recuperano i rifiuti del
quartiere di secondigliano scampia
quindi un quartiere particolarmente
problematico della città e fanno queste
opere meravigliose insomma di di riciclo
e di occuparsi dei rifiuti insomma
quindi è stata una giornata che ci ha
trasmesso delle emozioni particolarmente
intense è appunto lo stesso paul connett
questo esperto mondiale ha potuto
apprezzare poi quello che fanno i
carcerati e la loro essenza di bellezza
infatti poi in conclusione del suo
intervento ha detto io mi guardo e vi
vedo proprio belle se vogliamo è sempre
conclude 200 una cosa perché poi napoli
va in psicoterapia perché scegliere
questo tipo di comunicazione perché
quando il paziente viene da te viene
quando ha toccato la sua bruttezza la
vista diciamo in qualche maniera o
meglio si considera lui brutto
fondamentalmente la porta alla no con
onestà a differenza tanti sintomi che
camminano non c'è gente che non incontra
mai uno psicoterapeuta pre guardandoli
insomma regione che sta proprio
benissimo quella persona e invece c'è
grande autenticità per chi va in
psicoterapia perché ha visto propri
limiti e le proprie difficoltà e dice
voglio lavorarci ieri mi trovai a futuro
remoto a presentare il progetto mi
trovai a dire una cosa dice si dice a
napoli a mamma e senza mamma no perché
perché dello sguardo materno cioè quello
sguardo forse autentico che permette
quando la madre ovviamente sana stiamo
parlando comunque chi svolge una
funzione materna non voglio stare sul
femminile diciamo proprio sulla funzione
di cura perché lo sguardo autentico fa
bene perché la mamma guarda le nostre
puzze i nostri pannolini quando abbiamo
la febbre ci guarda nelle condizioni
peggiori e cia ma ugualmente come quando
ci stiamo per laureare sposare o
quant'altro e quello sguardo autentico
che permette cambiamenti è uno sguardo
che non è perbenista e uno sguardo che
sa guardare le proprie bruttezze
coltivare bellezza concludo
raccontandovi questo gioco delle co came
che molto emblematico noi cosa facevo il
sindaco compreso paul connet l'istituto
carlo iii una follia
all'interno del bosco di capodimonte
chiediamo di fare questo gioco di gruppo
prendete un pezzo di carta assegnate sul
pezzo di carta la parte più brutta della
città scrivetela è buttata nel cestino
tutti fanno questo gesto lo metto nella
munnizza diciamo dico adesso vi sentite
bene liberati ma in realtà non proprio
perché in realtà qualcuno se ne
occuparono di quel rifiuto
prendiamo il sacchetto parte una musica
incominciamo a passare questo sacchetto
tipo patata bollente si interrompe la
musica capita alla povera paola con la
nostra amica che era lì presente le
mettiamo un bel cartello futura
generazione
se non si mette mano nei rifiuti se non
si mette mano nelle bruttezze
raccontandole affianco alle bellezze e
possibile costruire un futuro migliore
allora che significa che dobbiamo essere
nel bel nei brutti no e belli e brutti
grazie